la parole est à monsieur françois
bonhomme pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la décentralisation de la fonction
publique
elle porte sur les conséquences de la
diminution sans précédent des dotations
de l'état aux collectivités
madame la ministre le gouvernement veut
en effet imposé au budget des
collectivités une diminution de la
ressource de 11 milliards d'euros de
2015 à 2017 dont 3 17 milliards dès 2015
cette décision ne va inévitablement
peser sur leurs finances prise à la
gorge les collectivités vont se
retrouver dans une position intenable
soit elles seront contraintes de
procéder à des arbitrages douloureux
affectant les services publics et
investissements locaux que vous affirmez
par ailleurs soutenir que dire alors des
conséquences également sur les
entreprises qui vivent fortement de la
commande publique soit les élus locaux
seront contraints d'augmenter les taux
d'imposition
pourtant monsieur le ministre vous le
savez la plupart des maires sont des
personnes responsables et accepte de
participer à l'effort national
oui un effort partagé mais encore
faut-il qu'ils puissent le faire selon
une trajectoire crédible réaliste compte
tenu de la rigidité de leurs dépenses
les collectivités ne pourront s'adapter
dans le temps à la brutalité avec
laquelle les dotations sont réduites
tout cela ne peut se faire sans
véritables études d'impact
tous les rapports à commencer par celui
de nos collègues philippe dallier
charles guené et jacques mézard toutes
les études le martel et confirme cette
sombre perspective
vous pourriez par ailleurs vous inspirez
utilement de l'analyse de françois
baroin que nous saluons quand nouveau
président de l'association des maires de
france
et qui estime je cite que le choc sera
brutal avec 30% en moins
d'investissements publics dans les trois
prochaines années et 10% moins
d'investissement local soit l'équivalent
de 0 2% 2 points de croissance
vous pourriez également écouter la mise
en garde du président du comité des
finances locales
andré laignel qui viennent déclaré je
cite que le gouvernement sera obligé
d'arrêter de couper les dotations parce
que le traumatisme sera tel qu'il faudra
prendre des mesures de relance effective
effets récessifs garantit donc dès lors
madame la ministre
ma question est la suivante allez vous
enfin écouté les élus locaux et accepter
une véritable négociation avec leurs
représentants afin de trouver ce point
d'équilibré nécessaire tant pour les
collectivités que pour notre pays merci
mon cher collègue
la parole est à monsieur jean marie le
guen secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le gouvernement
merci monsieur le président sur les
sénateurs mesdames les sénatrices
monsieur le sénateur je sais que vous
partager la préoccupation du
gouvernement de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques
non seulement vous voulez partager mais
si j'écoute les responsables de votre
parti vous souhaitez multiplier par 2
trouver 100 milliards et pas 50
milliards d'économies et j'ai du pain
j'ai peine à croire
j'ai peine à croire je le dis très
sincèrement et je pense ici que tout le
monde a peine à croire que vous pourriez
faire 100 milliards d'économies sans
toucher à la dotation globale de
fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales j'ai même la faiblesse de
penser que l'effort que vous demanderiez
ne serait-ce qu'au niveau de la justice
de l'équité et du bon fonctionnement de
l'état je pense que même l'effort que
vous demanderiez serait très nettement
supérieure et d'ailleurs le candidat que
vous avez soutenu à l'élection
présidentielle demandé dès 2012 qui est
une suppression de 10 milliards d'euros
dans la dgf direction des collectivités
territoriales
alors puisque puisque puisque vous
m'interrogez monsieur le sénateur je
voudrais rentrer maintenant dans les
détails pour essayer de faire en sorte
que vous soyez rassurés sur les
conséquences de cet effort qui est
demandé qui était un effort difficile
nous le concevons mais qu'il ait demandé
évidemment à tous d'abord vous le savez
vous avez vous l'avez souligné ces 11
milliards d'euros qui sont demandées sur
les trois ans qui viennent
c'est un effort que nous considérons
comme équitable par rapport aux autres
acteurs publics car il correspond au
poids de leurs dépenses dans la dépense
publique qui est de 21% au poids de la
dépense publique
monsieur le sénateur c'est fr représente
en moyenne 1,6 pour cent des recettes
totales des collectivités territoriales
pour 2016 ce n'est pas neutre
c'est un effort mais ce n'est pas non
plus je crois à l'étranglement que
parfois j'entends décrire ici ou là en
outre ces collectivités les plus
fragiles seront très largement préservés
grâce au renforcement de la péréquation
évidemment et sur ces éléments bien
évidemment vous serez très attentif pour
un certain nombre de départements que je
connais dans la région parisienne qui
sont n'est ce pas monsieur karoutchi
très sensibles aux questions de
péréquation enfin les recettes globales
des collectivités devraient continuer à
croître en 2015 notamment grâce à la
revalorisation des bases fiscales
notamment car grâce à l'évolution
positive de la cvae
vous avez noté également les mesures
prises en faveur du fctva qui consiste à
supprimer la réfaction de 0,9 point et
donc et surtout sortir de l' enveloppe
normée l'augmentation 2015 du fctva cela
représentera près de 200 millions
d'euros soit 70 points car nous savons
que 70% de l'investissement local et
porté par le bloc communal enfin il faut
larmes alors isation du marraine de la
taxe de séjour correspondra il faut donc
porter un regard global
l'ensemble de ces mesures pour
quantifier la baisse des ressources des
collectivités nous féministes
non là monsieur le sénateur les
informations que je pouvais apporter à
votre connaissance
merci monsieur le ministre